Channing Tatum helps you when you have
writer's block and you need to write
something funny or write something
creative
Channing Tatum helps to and I thought
you know Channing Tatum I I know his
work I am very familiar with his body of
work yeah you know my my my partner in
crime Jessica st. Clair and whenever we
come to like we're exhausted from making
choices all day we sit down we queue up
genuine Pony Channing Tatum on the stage
or even in the rupee's the reprise Magic
Mike XXL when he's like you know on a
sawhorse just it comes on the radio and
he just wants to like get down you know
I don't know something about that really
shakes it out of me you know she takes
it up my assistant and a couple of the
other ladies here at work wanted to go
see the sequel I hadn't seen the first
one they want to see the sequel and I
went with them and I was watching the
movie for like five minutes
when Channing Tatum is he's like working
with metal or he's in a something and he
starts dance and I said what I didn't
know what was happening
I didn't know what I knew what was
happening is you know did all the women
in America yeah yeah because that was
that was a really iconic scene in the
first film right that movie really took
me on a ride yeah
you know down settle down wanna see my
you
you